keeping my distance keeping our distance
yep standing up for the first time this
is a more sort of moving around kind of
a computer file
um yeah yeah we're on campus we're doing
some recording anyway let's let's do a
video
i thought today we could talk about a
cool cipher that sees quite a bit of use
and is i suppose i suppose one of the
only
real current rivals in terms of its
prevalence to aes
and that's the cha-cha 20 cipher right
so it's not a dance but it kind of
mimics a dance i guess is the idea
so this was written in about 2008 daniel
bernstein wrote this one
it's very cool very very elegant very
lightweight
which makes it really useful on low
powered devices and along with aes
or the advanced encryption standard that
we've covered in a previous video
remember this is going to be an
iterative process and what we want to do
is move these things around and permute
them
it's one of the only algorithms
recommended for use in the modern
transport layer security
1.3 right which is the encryption that
we use mostly on the web
so i guess a bit of background is that
you know almost everything
uses aes right and that's because um
nist ratified it as a standard
and just everyone implemented it and and
now everyone uses aes now
there's nothing wrong with aes as far as
i can tell um
the the attacks on aes have mostly been
theoretical they can't actually be
applied
at the scale necessary to break it most
machines
have a library that supports aes and so
browsers understand it web servers
understand it
but the point is sometimes made that
having just one algorithm isn't a
fantastic idea
because what if someone incredibly smart
like me releases a paper tomorrow
um that completely breaks aes right
let's put aside the ludicrousness of
that
you know theoretically it could happen
right not for me but you know someone
could find a mathematical weakness or
some other weakness in aes that we don't
know about or some kind of attack that's
very difficult to stop
and if that happens we need a backup
algorithm right and currently
one of the only you know major players
in this space i guess
is cha-cha right there are other albums
of course but this one's been a little
bit tested and looks pretty good now
unlike aes
cha-cha is a stream cipher right now in
practice that doesn't make a lot of
difference
in terms of implementation but basically
um
it uses what is essentially a hash
function
to mix up the key and your number used
wants
and your block number producing random
key stream and that's used with xor
to encrypt our data so if you remember
what we had
you know i'm using a board today because
you know the paper's not here
we had some sort of stream cipher so
this is our key stream generator
key stream generator or pseudo-random
function or whatever i don't think ksg
is a real thing i've just written that
down
and then you have a key that comes in
here so this is your secret key which in
the case of aes is 256 bits
what will happen here we also put in a
nonce right which is a number used once
and that's used to make sure that if you
don't change this key
you can generate different key streams
and that's quite important and we also
put in
our block number or counter and that
allows us to jump halfway through
a file if we want to based on this this
iterates and produces
a series of key bits so k naught k1
k2 and we xor that with our
message so m naught m one
m two and out comes our ciphertext
ciphertext one ciphertext two
subjects naught so this is in general
how a stream cipher works feeds a
specific
perhaps a char chart but the idea is
that the encryption for decryption
happened exactly like this so if we want
to decrypt this
we just go this way so we just put our
ciphertext in x or it with the same key
and out it comes so the question then is
just simply what is it that's
interesting about what char char does
in here how does it take these and turn
them into
key streams this is the problem with i
can't just tear up a piece of paper i
have to
right so char char is a bit like a hash
function in the sense that it takes a
block of data and it mixes it up and it
uses that for its keystream
so we have a block and we'll talk about
what goes in there in a moment
but it looks a little bit like the aes
block except it's bigger
so this is a 4x4 block and each of these
is 32 bits right so in total this is 512
bits
all right so we're going to fill that
with some data then we're going to put
it through a big round function
so this is our round function and i've
run out of space because this is
the most ludicrous aspect ratio of a
thing i've ever seen so
it comes out also with four by four also
of the same size
and this is all mixed this is our mixed
block and so this is essentially this
but completely jumbled up
and then we add these two together right
there we go and out comes our key stream
bit so knot k1 and these are going to
come out in
512 bit blocks but it's not a block
cipher because we just take that key
stream and we xor
it with the message and so it's a stream
cipher so
what happens in this round function well
the cool thing about this round function
is it only uses three operations
the implementation of aes is actually
quite complicated i mean
it's not in the sense that a lot of it
boils down to bit shifting and
and all and things but mathematically
aes is quite complicated
all that char chart does it's a sort of
it's what we call an arx
cipher so it's add
rotate and xor
now add is mod 32 edition so basically
you're just adding two integers together
and you don't carry any bits right so if
it overflows it just wraps back around
xor is obviously xor we've covered this
a lot before and rotate
is a bit shift and you wrap it back
around so for example if we were
wrapping around 001
and we were doing a rotate one to the
left
then we would i think actually in the
paper using this is the notation
then we would see something like 0011
right which is where this one has come
over here and everything's shifted to
the left
this is a bit like the color blocks in
the aes video where everything kind of
mixes up yeah it's a bit like that yeah
but this is happening on an integer or
you know
on a bit level for these bits are moving
along and what that's going to do
is move ones and zeros from somewhere in
these values to somewhere else in these
values
which over time when you combine it with
xor in addition it's going to start
mixing up all of this
a lot right and that's kind of the idea
you don't want to be able to reverse any
of this process because if you can
you're going to be able to read what the
key was like because the key goes in
here so what goes in here well there's
this
there's four constants because if you
had zero key
that and this was all zero the output
will be all zero that would be a problem
so there's four constants that come in
here
then you have 256 bits worth of key
so key here is where i write a lot of
k's
right these are the key bits and then
down at the bottom we have the block
number
which is sometimes 64 bits and the
nonce here right which is this like this
now
sometimes it's 64 bits in the current
standard you tend to do
something like this where the nonce is a
little bit bigger right there's
implementation reasons why you would
change the size of these two things
so your secret key goes in here this is
the number used once to make sure that
your keystream is nice and interesting
and this is where in the stream we are
in in our 512 bit chunks
so if you're watching a streaming movie
and you want to skip the boring bits and
go to the good stuff right where you
know the terrorists are taking over
nakatomi plaza
then you can set this block to the right
place and jump straight ahead right
that's the idea
okay so what happens in here
so we have these blocks right which
start off obviously with our key in
and end up being totally mixed up and
what we're going to do
is we're going to do 20 rounds of mixing
some of the rounds we do in columns so
we mix a
b c and d and then we mix this column
and then we mix this column a b c and d
in this column
so sometimes we mix diagonals so it'll
be a b c
d or a b c
d and you know down with diagonals and
the reason you do this is because you
want to jumble up
the bits and bytes should we say between
here in these columns but you also want
to do it in a diagonal so that bits
over here affect bits over here effect
bits over here and so you're
this is what you have you have good
diffusion right which is the changes in
in here
propagates to changes in everywhere
right which makes it very hard to
understand what's happened and break
this cipher
so what happens well each of these is a
quarter round so four of these this one
this one this one and this one will be
one round
four of these would be one round and we
do eat we do one of these and then one
of these one of these and then one of
these and we do that 20 times so 10 of
each
um as far as i know attacks on on char
char i've managed to get some
information out at maybe eight rounds
right and it's currently operating at 20
rounds so and i'm you know that's off
the top of my head so
the security margin is pretty high right
so what happens in here well we have
these
these are our integer words so we have a
b
c d right and then you have quite a
complicated process
for each quarter round so the first
thing you do is you take b
and you add it to a right like this
then you take this from a and you come
all the way over here
and you xor it with d this is just a
start then you come in here and you and
you rotate d
16 bits to the left and of course it
wraps back round
right then d comes in here and
it's oops summed with c right and then
let's just finish the whole diagram like
rather than walk through it so this
comes
down here xored with b and then b
is rotated 12. i should add i don't know
it's off by heart right because
this is difficult to remember right then
b comes in i'm going to run out of sheet
and then i'm going to have to start
drawing on these plugs so a comes down
here like this
yep then a just comes out here like so
so a comes along here like this
and is xor back again with d
d is rotated eight to the left then d
comes in here and is summed again with c
and c comes out here b is xord
c and then that's rotated come on draw
the plug
this looks this looks like trouble if i
draw on this right
i've reached the end it's something like
this but this will look great when we do
it in the video because you'll have
animated all this and it will look
fantastic right
even though i've totally botched up the
ending let's just finish that off
actually
i know what it is it's instagram format
isn't it yeah yeah so
that's a sum right without carry that's
an xor and that's a rotation so what's
basically happening is b is coming in
here
and being added to a and so those two
are now affecting this xor with d which
is being rotated and
affecting c and you see that this is
going to propagate bits and bytes around
very very quickly
and we're doing this over columns and
then over diagonals
and the result is a very very good
cipher right
the there's a few positives to doing
this over doing something like aes right
there are some negatives as well
but basically the the nice thing about
only using
add rotate and xor is that it always
takes exactly the same amount of time to
run this
there's no table lookups or clever
polynomial division or anything like
this that you have to do
there's no conditional branching which
means that basically no matter what your
key is if your keys are zeros or it's
half zeros
it doesn't matter this will take exactly
the same amount of time so coding this
in a safe way
for a cryptography point of view is
quite straightforward right
you know i'm sure my code wouldn't do a
great job but you get the idea
with aes although it's not that
difficult to get an implementation of
aes that technically works
it can be quite difficult to make it but
it's secure enough
because things like the time that it
takes to go into the cache and the time
it takes to develop certain operations
and power consumption things that you
can leak little bits of information
about what's going on in the inner
workings which can give the game away
right but this isn't really an issue
here
the other thing is that aes is helped
somewhat by the fact that modern cpus
have gallowa field arithmetic built into
them as actual instructions whereas
chancellor doesn't need any of that so
if you have a very low powered or old
device or a smart card or something
that doesn't really have clever
instructions this is going to be very
very quick
right so it's only marginally slow of an
aes and that's on a system that was
built to run aes
as fast as possible right so it's pretty
cool
um and it has a cool name when you
started it you mentioned something about
putting constants in because if
zeros yeah totally forgot to tell you
what they were yeah okay
so all right well let's just quickly
quickly we'll fix that shall we so yes i
mentioned that
in the at the beginning of the block you
have the key in here the nonce and the
id inside the counter up here we have
constants now the reason the constants
are there is just basically so that
zeroes don't you know completely break
it um
they're not a secret the constants are
just a string the string is
expand 32
uh byte
k all right so we've got
four space counts so that's four
that's four and that's four right and
then these get encoders ascii and stuck
in here
right and that's enough my sleeve number
so you remember that video we did
where if these were sort of weird
numbers you'd think well hang on a
minute where'd they come from are they
some kind of back door well no they're
just a sentence like
expand the first two by key which is
what this does right as long as it's
something obvious
you know they're just there to mix it up
a bit they're not a secret
are you doing the chartres steps as you
walk back and forth
uh yeah i mean what is a charger anyway
i don't know some sort of dance let's
not have me dancing on the internet
people don't need to see that this is a
edited version of a cypher called salsa
which is edited i think of rumble and so
on so there's lots of different
algorithms along this theme shall we say